[Music]
an unusual Ramadan
the first prayer of the Muslim holy
month is held in a makeshift mosque
Ramadan is not only about fasting it's
also a time for joy and celebration
but not this year
it is difficult to celebrate Ramadan in
a tent city conditions are difficult I
would never have imagined slippery in
Ramadan without a roof over our hates
Mahmoud gazelle and his family used to
live in a three-story house
it collapsed when the two powerful
earthquakes struck turkey and Syria in
early February
the gazelles are among about 5 000
people who have South shelter here they
all depend on Aid
yeah we provide two meals per day if
Towers in the coming days will also have
a temporary stage for traditional place
to be performed to help people overcome
the psychological trauma of the
earthquakes
says it's impossible to forget what
happened
she was trapped under the rubble of
their home for hours hugging her
grandchild and waiting to be rescued
they provide psychological support but
what use is it after we've lost
everything we built that house with
every penny we saved throughout our
lives during Ramadan I used to prepare
meals for my family now I don't even
have an oven to cook sahore for them
the earthquakes destroyed around a
thousand buildings in adiaman more than
8 000 people died those who survived
have turned to prayer especially during
Ramadan
[Music]
many people here say they hope their
time in tanks will be short and that
they will be able to move into houses
quickly but nearly two months after the
earthquakes that optimism is fading life
here is becoming increasingly difficult
and they're struggling to get used to
the new normal
Southeast turkey